MeMerci d'être là.
EnEn vous haver invité contenu e
cece drame au Texas.
1414 enfants assassinés dans la
clclasse, l'enseignant égalemen.
ApAprès l'accident en 2012,20
enenfants avaient été assassiné,
onon s'était dit plus jamais.
OrOr, on est revenu comme avant.
RaRaphaël, Monsieur Biden doit
s's'exprimer, il est de retour
d'd'Asie ce soir.
EsEst-ce qu'on va assister à la
mmême colère face a ce drame?
- - Malheureusement pour les
papartisans du resserrement des
cocontrôles des armes à feu,
prpresque le même résultat, rien
nene bougera d'un point de vue
lélégislatif de six n'a pas boué
enen 2012, ça ne bougera pas en
202022 surtout dans un contextùu
onon a des primaires en vue des
élélections.
C'C'est important de le
mementionner, parce que si vous
êêtes un électeur, un candidat
rérépublicain, c'est carrément
imimpensable dans le contexte
hyhyper polarisation de vous
prprononcer d'un possible
reresserrement des contrôles des
ararmes à feu.
LeLes républicains sont assez
nonombreux pour bloquer quoi que
cece soit.
UnUn resserrement moindre mal
mumusclé du contrôle des armes à
fefeu mêmes après cette nouvelle
hohorreur dans une école primai.
EnEn ce qui me concerne, c'est
imimpensable.
- - Que son congrès au Texas, vs
nene pensez pas qu'il voyait avr
dedes remises en question?
IlIls vont dire que ce n'est pas
l'l'arme qui a tué, c'est la
pepersonne.
- - même refrain depuis plus de0
anans.
EtEt ce qui est remarquable, c't
ququ'il y a à peine une semaine,
onon a eu une autre fusillade de
mamasse à bof allô ils sont qu'n
a a eu c'est un des arguments ls
plplus fondamentaux des
adadversaires du contrôle des
ararmes à feu qui a été démonté.
OnOn entntend que le problème da
pepersonne derrière l'arme à feu
etet que si on veut bloquer ou
frfreiner les méchantes personns
sosont armés, tout ce que sa
pensée toutes les personnes bon
ararmées.
MaMais la personne qui était
ararrivée, c'était le gardien et
ilil s'est fait abattre.
SiSi une question de mobilisatin
popolitique, la base républicaie
esest viscéralement opposée à tt
reresserrement prononcé du
cocontrôle des armes à feu et
c'c'est ce qui anime l'oppositin
dedes élus et des candidats d'un
ococéan à l'autre.
- - Michel, connaissait bien les
EÉtats-Unis, on va donc assister
àà la montée aux barricades du
ccôté des démocrates, les groups
s's'occupent de cela, mais
mamalheureusement ça risque de e
ririen changer?
- - Monsieur Biden va parler, je
coconnais déjà le discours,
MoMonsieur Obama l'a déjà fait.
IlIl y a plus de 400 millions
d'd'armes à feu en circulation t
mmême si demain on passait une
loloi pour interdire la bande
ararmes à feu, ce n'est pas
popossible, Raphaël a dit.
Y Y en a 400 millions en
cicirculation alors il y a quele
chchose d'un peu surréel.
OnOn va se trouver déjà en parte
rérépublicain pour dire que
c'c'était quelqu'un de dérangert
quque les services sociaux
n'n'étaient pas intervenus, mais
jajamais à cause des armes.
- - Il devait être fortement
dédérangé, il a tué sa grand-mè.
MaMais comment quelqu'un aussi
dédérangé peut avoir accès au
tetemps des armes.
- - Des gens qui souffrent de
mamaladies mentales il y en a ds
lele monde entier, avec une arme
didisponible, il y en a pas dans
lele monde entier.
L'L'Amérique, il faut dire que
l'l'Amérique vit des heures
didifficiles.
EnEn est revenue à un taux de
memeurtre qu'on n'avait pas conu
dedepuis le milieu des années 70
AuAussi un taux d'overdose, 110
00000 morts par overdose de 45 0
blblessés par arme à feu.
OnOn parlait de la tuerie de
BaBaltimore il y a eu cet homme
ququi a tiré 23 blessés.
- - Il y a peu de drames plus
trtristes des enfants qui se fot
exexécuter dans une salle de
clclasse.
AlAlors voici que sa survie en
nonouveau, c'est incroyable.
- - pour revenir au contrôle des
ararmes à feu, politiquement c't
cocompliqué.
OnOn réussit un peu mieux aux
EÉtats-Unis maintenir un registe
dedes armes à feu et un gros enu
auau Canada et même ici au Québc
onon l'a mis en place et le
gogouvernement l'a mis en placet
onon a beaucoup de difficultés à
amamener les gens qui détiennent
leles armes à feu as enregistré
eueux-mêmes.
PoPolitiquement, on nous voit
coconstamment dans ce dossier
paparce qu'on sait que c'est un
susujet très sensible et qu'il a
papas beaucoup de bonne volonté.
EfEffectivement, on rejette
totoujours les enjeux des armesà
fefeu sur le fait que CD gens ds
gagangs à Montréal aussi, on est
momoins dans un enjeu de
rerestreindre les danses
enenregistrer les armes à feu.
OnOn a de la difficulté d'avoira
cocontribution des gens qui
popossèdent des armes à feu.
- - Raphaël, c'est un pays
frfracturé et par des statistiqs
ququi remontent à la hausse.
OnOn a l'impression qu'il y a
bebeaucoup de plaies à penser.
- - Je vous laisserai peut-être
susur ce qu'on a pas encore vu,
c'c'est-à-dire que dans le
prprochain mois, on va avoir une
dédécision majeure de la cour
susuprême.
AÀ part celle de l'avortement,
mamais celle qui touche les arms
àà feu.
C'C'est très possible, sans allr
dede prédiction, surtout avec la
cocour de la composition actuel,
lala loi va obliger les gens qui
vovoudraient porter une arme de
popoing as enregistré et à
jujustifier qu'ils le fassent en
pupublic.
CeCe n'est pas une loi extrême,n
popourrait empêcher la totalité
dedes juridictions intérieures u
papays d'imposer ce genre de
rerestrictions.
EnEncore une fois, on a peut-
êêtre...
- - Raphaël, merci de d'être veu
dede nous voir.
OnOn va poursuivre sur l'adoptin
dudu projet de loi 96, je vais
vovous faire entendre
l'l'opposition, non je vais vous
fafaire entendre Monsieur Legau.
OnOn va entendre l'opposition
enensuite.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, premier
miministre du Québec
- - D'un côté, le Parti libéral
vovote contre parce qu'il trouve
quque la loi 96 va trop loin,
pupuis quel autre côté,
lele Parti québécois vote contre
lala loi 96 parce que le Parti
ququébécois pense que ça ne va s
asassez loin. Donc, on a d'un cé
unun parti qui dit que ça va trp
loloin, l'autre, pas assez loin.
DoDonc, on voit que la CAQ
etet dans une position équilibr.
CÇa va devenir très important
d'd'aller chercher les pouvoirsn
mamatière de regroupement famill
paparce qu'actuellement, le
gogouvernement fédéral accepte
lala moitié des immigrants
ququi ne parle pas français
dadans cette catégorie.
- - C'est intéressant parce qu'n
esest en pleine campagne Monsier
LeLegault dit qu'ils sont allés
plplus loin qu'il pensait devoir
alaller pour la langue française
etet qu'il veut aller rapatrier
l'l'immigration française.
CÇa sera son cheval de bataille,
ilil est déjà l'élection?
- - Oui la bataille va se fairet
ilil a les leviers pour faire
prpression sur Ottawa et il a
gagagné son pari sur toute la
liligne.
IlIl a polarisé juste assez, pas
trtrop et pour se faufiler danse
cecentre, entre les Parti
ququébécois qui trouve que ça va
papasser loin des libéraux qui
trtrouvent qu'il devra aller pls
loloin.
CeCe n'était pas parti comme ce,
paparce qu'il y a un an, les
lilibéraux avaient dit que c'étt
papas mal et le Péguy aussi.
AuAu gouvernement disait ce qu'n
esest en train de perdre notre
flfleuron nationaliste?
L'L'expression apolitique; six
momois et une éternité prend tot
soson sens stocke l'échiquier
popolitique a changé et les
lilibéraux doivent changer les
memeubles ils ont repéré leur
veveste de côté et le PQ aussi
veveut essayer d'aller gruger du
vovote chez les péquistes.
- - Le milieu dont parle Monsier
LeLegault, est-ce qu'il a réussà
atatteindre le milieu?
CoComme avec les cégeps, la loi
lilimite le nombre de places por
leles allophones, mais ils
éléliminent pas complètement ce
drdroit comme voulait le faire e
PQPQ.
IlIl y a des dispositions,
apapprendre le français en six
momois, est-ce que Monsieur
LeLegault a réussi son pari du
mimilieu?
- - Il dit toujours cela, sur la
loloi de la laïcité il avait dit
çaça, et il dit toujours ça mais
çaça ne fait pas de cela une boe
loloi.
JoJoue les oppositions les unes
cocontre les autres et ça le fat
papasser comme quelqu'un de modé
alalors que la loi à ses effetst
ilil y a des choses là-dedans qi
meme font beaucoup de choses coe
leles six mois pour apprendre le
frfrançais.
IlIl y a toutes sortes de choseà
réréconcilier au sein de cette i
mmême qui va être compliquée.
QuQui est un anglophone historie
etet qui ne l'est pas?
CÇa va être un peu à l'usure et
enen va voir que beaucoup de ses
didispositions moindres qu'on qi
a a administrées.
- - Il y avait des enquêtes
dedemandées aux employeurs qu'ee
ététait les exigences et 60 %
exexigeaient l'anglais, pas pare
ququ'il faisait des exportatiois
ouou une partie de leur chiffre
d'd'affaires ou États-Unis, mais
popour des communications
ininternes.
LeLes compagnies sont de plus en
plplus branchées entre elles et
l'l'anglais de plus en plus
nénécessaire.
LaLangue d'usage, l'homme publi,
mamais surtout langue de travai,
lala loi ne viendra pas corriger
cecela, elle va faire un peu de
prpression sur ceux qui refusait
cacarrément le français est pas
cacapable de faire 3, Cours de
frfrançais au Québec.
MaMais pour tous les anglophones
ququi ont fait des efforts pour
apapprendre le français, ça ne a
ririen changer.
- - On va regarder les points, e
popourcentage de 17 % qui sont
dadans les cégeps anglophones et
onon plafonne le pourcentage.
EtEt apprendre le français en sx
momois, autrement dit, pour les
réréfugiés, c'est après six moi,
lala communication avec le
gogouvernement, sauf pour la
sasanté, sera faite en français.
MaMartine, est-ce que dans la
popopulation francophone en
gégénéral, les gens se disent qe
c'c'est des avancées, est-ce que
c'c'est un plus dans cette
cacampagne qui commence quand me
dadans le baluchon de Monsieur
LeLegault?
- - Oui, c'est encore les
frfrancophones qui font et défot
leles gouvernements et Monsieur
LeLegault pourra dire qu'il avat
unun changement.
EsEst-ce que dans l'application
réréelle, ça va faire une
didifférence?
C'C'est un autre enjeu et Michea
totout àà fait raison, ça va ête
trtrès difficile d'appliquer le
sisix mois stocke ils vont avoir
bebesoin d'aide et c'est clair
c'c'est difficile d'apprendre le
frfrançais surtout dans un délai
auaussi court.
LaLa loi sera contestée devant s
trtribunaux, on verra ce que le
gogouvernement fédéral fera, mas
àà court terme Monsieur Legault
popourra s'en aller en campagne
leles râle et dans les campagnes
ququébécoises francophones et, s
lele premiers depuis 40 ans à
fafaire un pas de plus pour
prprotéger la langue française.
- - On va écouter la réaction ds
papartis d'opposition.
MAMARIE MONTPETIT, députée
inindépendante Maurice-Richard
- - Je vais voter... je vais vor
popour comme législatrice,
mamais aussi comme ex ministre
reresponsable de la protection t
dede la promotion de la langue
frfrançaise. C'est pas un projet
dede loi qui est parfait, mais e
pepense que c'est un projet de i
ququi a le mérite de faire avanr
lala protection de la langue
frfrançaise.
PAPASCAL BÉRUBÉ,porte-parole duQ
enen matière de langue française
- - Ce projet de loi, ce n'est s
lala suite de la loi 101, c'esta
cocontinuité de la loi 22 du pai
lilibéral du Québec en 74. Et ls
fifiers députés du Parti québécs
dede 1974 ont voté contre la loi
2222. Pourquoi? Parce que ça
alallait pas assez loin, on ne
prprenait pas au sérieux les dés
dede la langue. Et l'histoire
sese répète...
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - On va désamorcer cette claue
dede six mois qui s'appliquent
auaux nouveaux arrivants. C'est
unune clause qui manque de
cocompassion, et franchement,
c'c'est une clause qui est
susur le terrain absolument
ininapplicable. Il n'y a pas
dede raison de faire preuve
d'd'aussi peu de discernement.
- - Et une partie des extraits,
c'c'était ce matin.
SaSavait noter que la député Moe
pépétille à voter pour le projet
dede loi.
ElElle se que ce n'est pas
paparfait, mais que c'est une
avavancée.
AlAlors, sur le terrain
momontréalais, est-ce que Monsir
LeLegault est mieux armé ou mois
bibien armé?
EsEst-ce que c'est un plus pour
lului?
EsEst-ce qu'il tourne le dos aux
cicirconscriptions qui ne peut s
atatteindre, comment il voit, ds
lala prochaiaine campagne, Mont?
- - Je ne pense pas que ça soita
prpriorité Montréal, parce que i
çaça l'était, il aurait travailé
leles choses différemment.
C'C'est le vote francophone quia
alaller chercher et s'il peut
raramasser quelques billes, il a
lele faire, mais Morgan n'est ps
lala priorité.
- - Montréal n'est pas la prioré
dede la CAQ, c'est beaucoup plus
lele régime qui va aider avec
MoMontréal, mais la loi contre s
9696 c'est de resserrer les
boboulons de la Loi 101.
AlAlors comme ils changent riene
fofondamental ça ne changera pas
lala situation du français à
MoMontréal.
L'L'avenir nous le dira, mais
c'c'est de prendre le même cadre
quque la Loi 101.
JeJe ne pense pas que c'est une
rerecette gagnante0.
- - il y a des éléments qui vont
plplaire aux gens qui viennent à
MoMontréal comme sur l'île de
MoMontréal il y a Bourget est
PoPointe-aux-Trembles qui vote
popour la CAQ, mais dans les
cocouronnes, il y a l'obligation
dedes services en français et ds
3,3, Cours obligatoires au cégep
etet ils sont obligés de adressr
enen français, salvateur dans ls
babanlieues et dans les gens qui
sosont sur le territoire des
grgrandes régions montréalaises
ququi viennent parfois au centr-
viville.
- - Mais avoir plus de poids
MoMontréal, c'est pas dans les
prprojets à court terme de la C?
- - La CAQ est assez en santé,
alalors Montréal ce n'est pas
tetellement, s'il y a du
cocollatéral, ils vont le prend.
IlIls ont Bourget, Pointe-aux-
TrTrembles, est divisé sur
cecertaines circonscriptions
frfrancophones, mais le projet e
loloi est beaucoup plus pour les
rérégions, pour les francophone,
etet je pense que Lucas raison
popour dire que les couronnes
pepeuvent être séduites par ce
prprojet de loi parce que les
cocouronnes prennent plus qu'à
memesure du déclin du français
ququand ils vont à Montréaéal.
AlAlors que la CAQ arrive avec e
prprojet de loi, ça veut dire
ququ'ils ont fait un pas.
MaMais tout est dans la façon dt
onon va l'appliquer et on n'a ps
vrvraiment décrite et ça va être
didifficile de mesurer les
avavancées et si les nouvelles
memesures du projet de loi vont
êêtre efficaces.
- - Et Dominique Anglade, ça été
unun parcours compliqué, Luc, is
onont proposé quelque chose sur
leles 3, Cours de français de ps
auau cégep qui allait être des
cocours de programme, mais
mamaintenant... Mme Anglade à
cocomprendre autre chose?
- - Elle a d'ailleurs essayé
cocompare d'autres choses, maisa
n'n'a pas fonctionné.
ElElle a proposé une loi-cadre s
rérégions.
MaMalheureusement, c'est tombé e
jojour de la mort de Guy Lafleur
etet même chose pour les Parti
ququébécois qui a essayé
d'd'approfondir les questions sr
leles services à domicile.
OnOn se rend compte que plus one
rarapproche de l'élection, moins
leles grands programmes contentt
c'c'est ce que Mme Anglade est n
trtrain de faire, elle reconnaît
l'l'électorat.
SiSi elle est capable de croître
unun peu.
- - Michel, gros défi pour les
lilibéraux?
- - Mme Anglade - dans les pieds
avavec cet amendement qu'elle a
esessayé d de retirer.
LaLa communauté anglophone voult
susurtout qu'on lui dise qu'il
n'n'était pas responsable du
dédéclin du français.
CeCe n'est pas parce qu'il y a s
enengagements Montréal que le
frfrançais ne va pas bien, elle
n'n'avait pas réussi alors direa
cece qu'il y a des gens, persone
n'n'a voté pour la CAQ dans le
WeWest de Lille, mais il y a des
gegens qui ne sont pas satisfais
dedes libéraux.
- - Il y a une règle non écriten
popolitique ici de ne jamais
séséduire un électorat et
ababandonner les le ras que tu s
dédéjà, et Madame Anglade... l